hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until done there's
only one new butterfly here and it's
obvious what it was Mike made a friend
the wolf guide to Mike around the
Santorum except now I left the wolf
behind his friends dead okay but there's
only two more flowers or flowers
butterflies left half of on the same
page but I guess that would have been
fine if Jess is dead and Matt's dead so
that makes more sense
I thought jess was just gone but that's
why everyone was so pissed that killed
the bird I was just doing it on a whim
who would have thought that it would
have that profound of an effect I had no
idea that behind it but at least I made
that KitKat joke pretty cool right okay
let mine an important discovery so I've
been trying to gather as much
information as possible so now I need to
go find wolfy and follow him to the
depths of whatever hell we're going into
because I know it's going to be so much
fun I can't wait to approach it
I need lot to find and then die horribly
a vine okay so where did wolfy go porky
alright so what do we got going on here
any totems
you see a totemo doki then yeah it
seemed good I've known a lot of good
things in my time this seems like the
anti good alright so if somewhere around
here I need to keep to the right side
cuz this guy's gonna try to grab me by
my gonads he's gonna go to grab me and I
am not gonna like it
hey Bujji okay don't mind me while I
bump into your face with my crotch
alright I'll go first don't worry I'll
go first it's all good it's all good
breath whoa hello a little framerate
oh why would I shoot that wait go left
I like left less sounds good this looks
good oh wait left is bad oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh oh god dammit I
accidentally hit a button oh no I think
I didn't even think about that I thought
he was gonna come at me oh no did I do
bad not that one
okay maybe not maybe not maybe not maybe
not this is okay
what I didn't know I still have that who
would have thought I still have that
come on you douche you don't need me to
help hi Poochie how'd you get there
that's really weird
I say oh don't move oh I'm not moving
the controller no movie controller I'm
legitimately not moving
okay there we go that's exactly what I
was doing before
no no douchery
[Applause]
just stop talking you dick that's
exactly what I did last time and yet I'm
alive now not that [ __ ]
yeah come on you thought of birds you
slice that guy's head off like it was
nothing but apparently I'm alive huh why
are you hunting it now you knew where it
was before why are you being weird huh
damn it if it seems like I'm going
against Mike I very damn sure I'm gonna
guess Mike Heath left a bad taste in my
mouth a long time that sounds weird but
ID rub me the wrong way and he seems
like a douche but I don't know maybe I'm
cheering for him he made a puppy friend
so I guess he can't be that bad oh oh I
know this
well what's gonna do no need to do that
oh just have been a waste of a bullet
why are you kidding me what are you
kidding me
did it get him or didn't get him okay
here we go oh hey I remember you
enough for me for all ya do I need to
it's a waste of bullets isn't that a
waste of bullets he was freaking in a
cage right okay so it oh boy oh and I
was a waste of bullet okay that was
definitely a waste a bullet but maybe
just to get bought maybe he would have
come after me a little more I don't want
you to shoot him do i I think I didn't
need to shoot the one on the cage or in
the with the chain I'm gonna shoot oh no
I'm not nevermind I'm gonna run very
fast
[Applause]
hope I have enough bullets or no hope I
have enough muster I got your [ __ ]
pansy what am i doing oh god I gotta go
come on come on come on come on come on
wait to shoot the bear suit the bear
suit the bear suit the bear suit the
Bears hit the bear bear bear I killed
him
that was the Windigo spirit being
released where's Poochie
where's Poochie where's [ __ ]
where's Poochie where [ __ ] go did
Poochie go through but you better have
gone [ __ ] better have gone through
would you better have gone through will
cheap Pucci better be around here would
you better be here would you better be
here I don't see a totem or anything I
don't know how many shotgun shells I
have left but I think I used exactly as
many as I needed I should've grabbed
more but apparently the game didn't want
me to okay why did I come down here why
did I come down here or Mike I didn't
choose to come down here Mike came down
here of his own volition dumb hoochie
better be around here she better be
I'm more emotionally invested into the
wolf than I am any other character in
this game except for Chris he's cool
Chris is cool I like Chris Chris cool
booty puppy Wampus who's a good Raul
rule who wants a ruby Rach oh sure told
him anywhere
I'm trying to keep an eye out but I
don't see anything on the ground seems
like it's still a dangerous place so
maybe there's no - you know lucky me no
likey me no likey me no no no no likey
hellooo booty store cracked open a bit
nope can't open it okay seems to be a
lot less choice going on oh hi oh no
that I thought that was a thing that was
just a wind okay I thought that was a
doorway
like it like it
barricaded you [ __ ] bear caddy a maroon
yay I'm smart and now go hey buddy come
on down where the hell was he the whole
time
oh I'll catch you on the flip side huh
where was he at least he's alive I think
I sure I'm in a tizzy wow that one's
sturdy hi what are you gonna do putting
in it what are you gonna
whoa I don't know what those are yeah I
need to get them into those things
[Applause]
oh is that how physics work
oh oh oh okay all right we're just gonna
accept the fact that the blast wave push
the doors open but blew it apart besides
blow blowing media pieces is that
because I didn't shoot him also into the
pit first oh cool it was probably like
intentionally done like that so that
there would be one left you know just
for a threat cuz otherwise the game
would be over there you are I've been
worried sick about you
I thought I killed you after your sex
rant oh man are you doing so good though
congratulations you survived for some
reason your skin wasn't ripped off in
little chunks your intestines weren't
ripped out and eaten while you were
still alive good job you did good I
would say doesn't didn't matter had sex
but you you didn't have that so hey
she's a wife they're doing something
stupid
where are the adventuring crew
boobity boobity boo yeah why didn't you
just go with him when he was going
reassure you reassure we're not leaving
you behind we're sticking together
Mike we'll just have to wait
yeah now that we're super lovers now
that's all that matters is our love our
unrequited love unrequited I don't think
that's the right word for the situation
but love love through the power of
friendship and love is their totem on
the wait let me double check that I
didn't miss anything here because I want
to be thorough maybe because I told
Emily the truth now her aggression came
out earlier instead of coming out later
because you didn't count on her she's
kind of gonna be a mean person but now
it's already out in the open
maybe that's good maybe that's good
maybe I'm doing a good maybe I'm doing a
bad that's equally possible
oh no later we got no totems weird
camera angle but I'll take it
anything over here ah totem totem totem
I knew I knew I knew ooh that's black is
that black death Josh does not look
happy danger I thought that was a death
totem Josh did not look happy there Josh
didn't look happy hang on let me I want
to see something else too because okay
it looks pitch-black but Josh ain't no
do so good
Oh Josh turned to cannibalism look at
his teeth his teeth are a little freaked
up boy I didn't see that first glad I
looked at it again I'm so smart and good
at games
man I'm so great look at me he's turned
into a wand ago though so we should
shoot his face maybe I don't know still
don't know let's get out a little bit
instead of walking let's walk a little
butt romping Lee because that's the only
difference I saw if you had the pistol
you could shoot it open because yeah it
was this what about this
oh yeah going to the super grand idea
always good in the horror game choices
here maybe we should but maybe we should
yeah no I'm too wimpy sorry wait hang on
is it theirs okay there is a way to back
out of it I wanted to make sure because
I I needed to look around a little bit
Chris you don't okay buddy witch what
happen to you we love you I love you I'm
gonna make sure you get out of this
alive no matter words okay it's
definitely locked but maybe if we all
tried okay there's definitely no other
way to go so down into the sewers cuz
that's a good idea
can't wait to do more good ideas okay
anyway let's go down a bunch of high
schoolers who somehow managed to still
split up even though we were doing fine
come on
yeah I'm strong gotta go gotta go let's
go let's go cuz apparently there's only
one wand to go left okay this may be the
last place I would want to be right now
uh-huh
so who's going first after you yeah good
job volunteering like that you think
this the tunnel to the sanatorium of
course it is where else would it go
these people are very dumb dumb dumb why
didn't they go together why would my go
off by himself move it
all right I'm trying ash that was a
little mean come on what happened to
love love you know smoochy smooth this
is really slow by the way this has been
really slow what is wrong anyway um hey
we should close this right ha I mean
what if something's following us
yes fine close it but we gotta keep
moving
wait no what what what the hell wait
what what wait what is this baloney what
what is no no what is know what huh Lily
Lily Lily wait
I don't like this these people are too
stupid for their own good they're never
gonna survive with this level of
stupidity on their team what the hell so
such friends goodness gracious
all right fine whatever else we got
it's amazing how many people on this
mountain somehow resorted to cannibalism
by the way who's there anybody Jessica
investigate voice oh crap oh no that
might have been bad if it was a wander
whoo
that was just impersonating a Wibbly
whoa oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no I'm hoping I'm hoping that
it's not gonna be what I think it is oh
look at least I found a totem so this
must be some sort of right way to go
okay
loss oh no oh no oh no hang on wait no
wait wait no sound in the mind by Ashley
who is that
it looks like it might be Josh yeah blue
shirt kind of overalls look that was
what Josh was wearing right I'm pretty
sure that's Josh but now I've got two
totems about Josh kind of contradicting
each other Oh God oh I don't like this I
don't like this
hello okay it's a I've got a German who
it was just gonna open it right up
[Applause]
[Music]
no nope nope nope nah nope ain't no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
I'm no I'm no see you think I'm just
gonna put up with that bull no all right
no yeah no no I'm not gonna put up with
that I'm not gonna put up with it I'm
drawing the line in the sand no I'm
gonna play through the whole [ __ ]
game again because no I refuse no and no
means no I'm gonna play through the
whole goddamn game again the whole game
again I'm gonna play through the whole
frickin game again I like Ashley too
much for my stupidity to get in the way
of her love I'm gonna make sure that she
ends her experience here on this
mountain in the happiest way being bones
owned by Chris because I love deserves
so I'm gonna end this episode here I'm
going to start an entirely new game I'm
gonna play through the whole game and
you know what I'm gonna play through it
correctly I'm gonna play through it the
way that I'm supposed to play
now that I know what I'm supposed to do
I'm gonna get to the point where they
walk in a sewer and then I'm gonna
experience the Russell game those dreary
completed completionist mark gerard did
finish these cysts i can accept my
mistake with Matt I can accept that I
can accept it I can accept that well I
cannot accept is the [ __ ] that you
just made me watch you freaking stupid
mark EMU I'm yelling to myself cuz I'm
freaking idiot you how dare you how
could you lie like that actually what
school so I'm gonna play through the
entire game again from start to now
doing things the correct way in the way
that they're meant to be and then I will
continue the game on from that point cuz
no so thank you everybody so much for
watching I apologize to all of you for
being an idiot but next time you see me
I will be a million times wiser with ten
times that many totem please love and
Chris critical too so thanks again
everybody I'll be back in no time
episodes will still continue there won't
be in a delay from what you guys see
continue so thank you again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
it was so obvious even Ashley was saying
no no no no no oh no oh god no or no no
I didn't even check I didn't even call
down like my mind in my mind I was like
if a winner goes down there it would
have been able to break that open in no
time
[ __ ] you Josh